now by the former u.s army green beret
and afghan war veteran lieutenant
colonel scott manor maybe i should call
you lieutenant given that it's an
americanism um talk to me about how we
got it so wrong
you know you would think after vietnam
and and everything that happened there
um that we would learn some of these
lessons but unfortunately you know it
seems like we haven't and and having
fought several tours there it it's hard
to watch
but we certainly on the timeline for
withdrawal and how we phased that out
um you know we we left a lot of people
behind and it is it is gut wrenching
that is
that is an appropriate term to use it is
a gut-wrenching thing to watch
you have friends colleagues there who
you're trying to get out of the country
yeah you know for a lot of us uh who
served in that country we have friends
there
who we served alongside uh you know the
nature of of our work and special forces
is to work very very deeply in the
indigenous communities and and we built
a lot of strong relationships and there
were a lot of people who stood up and
you know one of the things k that i
don't think is getting clearly
articulated is that the the afghan
forces really took on the brunt of the
fighting for the last three to five
years they endured a heavy amount of
fighting and certainly the heavier
amount of losses you know so there was
no unwillingness to fight um you know
what what was missing were a lot of
things like air power and and and you
know the advisers alongside them i mean
the army is only 20 years old so
um you know it's it's there's a lot of
people right now who are on the run and
again it's just a really hard thing to
watch
but um president biden would say that a
lot of military hardware was left behind
for the afghan security forces so why
did it go so wrong was it because uh the
taliban are ruthless cunning fighters or
was it that the security forces just
weren't ready
you know i just i think that hardware is
hardware uh those are just tools and you
know what the um a lot these are
fledgling forces even though it seems
like i mean 20 years is a long time
we invested most of our youth our entire
adult life uh fighting over there and
working over there uh with these folks
and but what i can just tell you is that
you know this insurgent is an extremely
adept insurgent and and very organized
and have been playing applying
consistent pressure against coalition
forces and certainly the afghan forces
for many many years um and it takes time
it takes time to build that kind of
capacity and they needed more time
certainly with our advisors at their
side and i hope that's a lesson that the
whole the western community that nato
learns is that when we go in capacity
building is a real thing but we when you
break it you buy it you've got to stay
in there and and work shoulder to
shoulder for the duration and and it
doesn't have to be a hundred thousand
troops but we do need to stay with them
during these rough times but 20 years is
a long time um i was speaking to someone
who who advised president trump about
the withdrawal and he said we couldn't
stay there forever
well you know what i would point to is
there you know the united states uh
great britain they have they have a long
history of capacity building and and
working surgically in countries that are
at risk and helping them build up you
know an antibody to uh extremism which
is a local populace or a partner force
that's willing to stand their ground i
mean i point to the philippines to
colombia certainly for the united states
where we've had immense success in doing
that and and i think it's something that
as we face violent extremists like isis
and al-qaeda in the future we're going
to need the ability to build capacity in
these countries and it's a multi-decade
endeavor but we can't do it with these
heavy footprints like we did in
afghanistan it's got to be a more
surgical footprint with commandos
advisors marines and we have we have a
history of doing that and we just need
our
our politicians and our bureaucrats to
catch up
what do you think is going to happen now
as far as u.s military personnel is
concerned on the ground
you know i'm just i'm trying to really
uh
let folks know that our our military's
on the ground doing what they're what
they need to do the british military we
need to pray for them we need to we need
to we need to support them and really i
would ask that our politicians and
everybody involved in this stop blaming
other politicians and stop blaming other
administrations and certainly stop
blaming the afghan people right now we
have a chance to do something at least
somewhat right and get in there and get
as many people out as we can as many
afghans out as we can let's focus on
that let's focus on working together
standing shoulder to shoulder and
certainly stop us
assigning blame
in the middle of this crisis we can do
that later let's focus on the mission at
hand one of our former politicians uh
described that as uh examining your
entrails in the midst of battle never a
good idea lieutenant colonel uh it's
good to talk to you thank you for
staying up for us uh this morning uh in
florida appreciate it